musicality is a Cornerstone of dance and
also I'd argue with flow Arts
a remarkably difficult to frame or teach
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
over the course of the past year I've
been posting videos breaking down my
approach to how we dance with our props
and in this video I want to zero in on
one particular aspect of that
how we can add musicality to our flow
and POI spinning but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinski and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission without a doubt one of the
most frequent pieces of feedback that I
get on my flow is that I have an
excellent sense of musicality when I
dance and spin which fun fact is also
one of my favorite pieces of feedback to
receive and that's not by accident it's
a thing that I've worked to hone over
the course of many years and still
something that I consider to be an
active area of improvement and
workshopping for me and it is a thing
that I'd love to pass on to other people
not only to see if I can get more flow
artists out there dancing but also to
help give people who are flow Arts
adjacent a lens through which to view
and understand our work but before I can
teach you how I approach musicality and
flow we should probably answer a very
fundamental question
what exactly is musicality real quick if
you like videos on POI spinning and flow
Arts make sure to subscribe to the
channel so that you're the first to know
when I upload a new tutorial review Vlog
or flow session now back to the show I
have come through a lot and I do mean a
lot of dance blogs and videos online
searching for a simple coherent
definition of musicality and much like
how we use the word flow in a very
amorphous sense so too does the dance
world have a very fluid approach to
defining musicality the definition I
came across that I most identified with
was this so what is musicality some
describe it as the way in which a dancer
expresses music through their bodies and
their movements others have described
musicality as the dancer's ability to
become one with the music in short dance
musicality can be defined by how dancers
hear interpret and move to music I like
this definition because it gels well
with how I frame musicality in my mind
when I dance and spin to music I'm
trying to to emphasize different accents
Dynamic changes and even lyrics as they
pop up through that music
and I think this is something that a lot
of people latch onto with my personal
style but it also has to be said that
even this definition leaves a lot of
room for interpretation and expression
different people will experience
different parts of Music in different
ways some will latch on to the nuances
and dynamics of specific instruments
others to the groove B to the music many
will focus on lyrical content or the
unique phrasing of a vocalist to say
nothing of how specific this can be to
genre or Dynamics in the music itself
and of course whenever you bring
together two art forms there's the
question of how do they complement each
other does our dance exist to support
elements of the music or to emphasize
features we think are important for the
listener to pick out is the music merely
background accompaniment or integral to
not just our choreography but also the
message we are hoping to convey to our
audience dance like all forms of art is
always going to be more than a little
subjective but with that said I know
what I think looks good I've been
breaking down my own style of Dance as
well as the styles of other point
answers I really respect to identify
specific moves techniques and stylistic
flourishes that add up to what I find
appealing your mileage on many of these
techniques may vary but I still want to
present what I've learned in the hopes
that it helps other people who are
navigating these same Waters in the
course of that work I've identified five
key areas where we can emphasize
elements of Music those areas are beat
accents phrase accents Dynamic accents
vocal accents and POI flourishes you
might be noticing that several of these
correlate pretty directly to aspects of
music as an art form itself and that is
certainly not by accident so let's take
a look at each of these areas and what
we can do with our POI to accompany
enrich and Adorn the music that we are
dancing and Performing to let's start
out with beat Accents in my mind the
absolute master of this form of
musicality is the British POI spinner G
he has a style that uses a variety of
different techniques to land percussive
instacato POI tricks right on the very
beats of the music that he's performing
to his performance at San Francisco dcom
is a perfect example of this I did a
reacts video to this video last year
where I go through his performance in
detail and I'll link to that in the
video description but here are some
major takeaways for our current purposes
one of the biggest is that POI zero
points make for a wonderful visual
counterpart to the sounds of aggressive
drums such as snares and kicks the
stalls and g-pops make for excellent
moments when the POI seemed to pierce
the air in the same fashion that the
drums do other tricks that work here
include spiral wraps shotguns and
vertical stacking
[Music]
but are there ways to Accent beats
without having to do zero points in
order to get there yes but they each
come with asterisks one of the best
techniques I've seen is to time the tips
of flower petals to hit on specific
beats you really have to emphasize the
tips of those pedals to make the effect
land however as flower petals can
frequently become a little mushy if
you're not careful
[Music]
other Alternatives include the use of
tricks that perhaps don't have the sharp
edges of zero points but do include
direct movements either from the POI or
the hands themselves examples here
include linear extensions 1.5 and waist
wraps and fountains if you really make
your arrival points pop
[Music]
you'll be coming back back
that's not to say we can't accent beats
with curves however one great example of
this in action is to time the downbeats
of a pattern to land on the beat
butterflies and the edges of carryover
patterns like fountains and caps work
well for this but watch your timing it's
easy to get slightly off and the effect
then will be completely lost
[Music]
hello
by the same token we can emphasize Beats
by changing the volume of our POI
movements in specific tricks for example
we can perform static spin butterflies
on the downbeat and expand them to full
arm extensions on the BackBeat I made
use of this technique a lot in my recent
performance video to Goodbye by who is
fancy I'd also be remiss if I didn't
point out that there are some really
special cases that happen very rapidly
that we can use to Accent drum fills for
example staggered stalls in the style of
Mel or a personal favorite Zan's Diamond
both work fantastically for this purpose
you're lying away
[Music]
and of course we have loads of options
for what we can do with our bodies
regardless of what the POI are doing to
Accent those beats too we can do dime
stops kicks pirouettes and head checks
to name just a few to land those beats
as the POI spins in a variety of
different ways bonus points you combine
body movement with the point movement to
really Drive things home doing this with
vertical stacking is easily one of my
favorite techniques
and how do you have
and while I think the beginning of poi
throws are a little too gooey to be a
good accent you can absolutely turn
catching the POI into an accent
especially when you get your whole body
into it try doing these with a head
check a pirouette having to catch
Ricochet through your whole body the
possibilities are endless
[Music]
eyes follows Right Care you'll note our
beat accents run the gamut from being
very sharp and specific to being a
little softer put some thought into what
the drums sound like in the song that
you're dancing to and what Contours of
poi movement might be a good fit not
only for how the drums sound but also
how they make you feel of course just
hitting every or even most beats of a
given piece of music would get pretty
dull quickly there's more going on in
music than just the beat after all
there's also Melody Melodies can go up
and down they can move around a note
before arriving at it and they're also
frequently one of the first elements of
music that people hear and latch onto as
they're listening to it so how do we get
POI to accompany melodies or phrases
well here's a few ideas every Melody has
a place where it starts and it stops as
well as points where it sustains notes
versus pausing or popping out more
staccato notes you can perform sequences
of poi moves that line up with these
patterns creating phrases of poi
movements that start and stop with the
melody or that punctuate those staccato
notes with some of the same tools we
used for beat accents
this definitely gets a little bit more
subjective but I also believe that
sounds and Melodies have shapes some
Melodies can be small and intimate
whereas others are sweeping and epic try
moving your POI in ways that suggest
those same shapes from smaller to larger
movements
[Music]
foreign
and of course most Melodies tell a story
even without the lyrics involved you can
act out the trajectory of that Melody
taking it from places of Hope to despair
act out the way the melody feels with
your body language and the volume of
your poetrics to see where that takes
you
[Music]
but there is another piece of music that
I'd argue is one of the most important
pieces of it one in which there's a
great deal of range and a lot of
diversity in how it is explored and that
is Dynamics I'm a child of the 80s and
90s so I first became aware of this in
the alternative rock music of the 90s
Smells Like Teen Spirit made famous the
habit of going from quiet verses to loud
choruses but that barely scratches the
surface of the many ways musical
dynamics are practiced let me show you
some examples and how you can use your
POI to accompany them first up one of
the most common ways of distinguishing
between different parts of a song is
simply to change the melody or phrasing
of the music likewise you can change
things up in any number of ways from
changing timing and direction to how
you're phrasing your POI combos you
remember how we learned to accompany a
melody in our last section here's your
opportunity to switch things up
too late
another technique that's super common in
pop punk music is to do Tempo shifts
going between normal and half time or
normal and double time you can reflect
that Tempo change in your own spinning
and either release or build tension
[Music]
and of course there's the Nirvana
formula of going from quiet to loud you
can emphasize this shift with volume
changes very easily because well it
literally is a volume change
[Music]
another favorite Dynamic shift I
encounter a lot in popular music is
switching Rhythm phrasing between verses
and choruses for example having very
staccato verses that give way to
choruses with more of an open and free
feel you can do the same with your POI
switch between the beat accenting
techniques that we discussed in our
first section versus something that
feels like it has more flow to it
connecting together different tricks and
techniques that have a broader sweep to
them
[Music]
but not all Dynamic shifts are purely
about going from verses to choruses
sometimes there are Dynamic shifts that
add or remove instruments embellish
sections you've otherwise already heard
before or drop out entirely to build
anticipation it's quite common for us as
POI Spinners to be obsessed with motion
but finding Stillness can occasionally
highlight the moments when we are moving
think about this as a tool for when
there's space in the music versus
sections filled with instrumentation
[Music]
I heard
and also bear in mind that you have a
lot of options when dropouts do happen
you can use this as a moment of
suspension in your accompaniment to seem
at one with the music
[Music]
or you can choose to keep a movement
that suggests a kind of stagnation in
anticipation of the music returning
pendulums are great for this doing this
can help break up those drops for your
audience and give them something to hold
on to and help build anticipation or
Bridge gaps
[Music]
foreign
example of this I'd specifically like to
cite is a recent video by glow Stringer
Stacy Hotta where she takes an extended
build and basically Works through three
different sections of flow showcasing
different skill sets so that when the
beat finally drops she brings all those
Styles together it's a masterful
approach to adding to what's going on in
the music and finding ways to add to the
audience's anticipation thus far we've
talked a lot about aspects of the
instrumentation of music but we've kind
of left out the part that most people
are listening for when they listen to
pop music and that's vocals part of
where this gets tricky is that it's also
usually one of the most personal parts
of a song a person can feel like they're
speaking directly to you or Hit Upon a
lyric that summarizes concisely a
feeling you never knew how to put into
words so how do you put something that
can be so intimate into your movement
well here are a few suggestions we can
take some of the same tools that we used
in our section on Melody and phrasing
and apply them here what's the Contour
or the shape of the vocal line does a
note get belted out you can show that
off with a broad sweeping POI Move Like
an extension or inspin flower
[Applause]
[Music]
in this same vein it can be challenging
but you can create movement phrases that
feel both percussive and sweeping take
POI movements like staggered stalls or
stall Chasers that both hit sharp
accents but also clearly are part of a
bigger movement when you bring them to a
halt it also reads as a rest
[Music]
less
but what about if we want to engage with
the lyrics directly here's one
suggestion what if you think of the
vocals as being a conversation how would
you respond to the person saying these
things to you would you be angry
skeptical approving indifferent put that
into movement and it makes the music
feel much more Interactive
[Music]
it's hard to believe myself
is there a specific action or object
mentioned in the lyrics try acting it
out this can really easily lead to
moments that feel a little too cute or
obvious but it can also be a fun way to
play off words that you like your
mileage may vary
now
he would get another
life
so we've covered a lot so far from
different aspects of instrumentation to
vocals but I also just want to point out
something about our very premise that I
think is really important when we spin
or dance to a piece of music we are also
adding our own art to it we should
strive not just to accompany that music
but to add to it after all there are
things that POI can do that music or
other forms of Dance Can't what makes us
unique and how can we add that to this
puzzle to create better choreography or
performances that's frankly a topic so
big that it should probably be its own
video but here are a few quick
suggestions this first one is going to
center around something really specific
that I think POI does really well create
incredibly Dynamic and enormous volume
changes going from a three beat weave to
Giants creates movement dynamics that
most other kinds of dancers can only
dream of one example for those volume
changes as a tool is to emphasize
Dynamics and Music Volume we've talked
about this a little already but you have
an opportunity with POI to Showcase not
just how epic the music sounds but also
how epic it feels as you take up space
go big or go home
[Music]
another thing point is really well
create really explosive Tempo shifts
because a POI is essentially a big third
degree lever we can get the heads of a
set of poi moving faster than any part
of our bodies could ever hope to we can
combine that with our last example to
use the volume Tempo and levels of our
spinning as a way to visually represent
the ups and downs of both vocal and
musical Melodies hit a high note hit a
big high trick hit that chorus with a
quick Tempo shift too
[Music]
but perhaps the thing POI is best at is
turning human movement into something a
little bit more mathematical geometric
or abstract in the same way that college
kids of my generation spent way too much
time watching abstract visualizations on
their computers as they listen to music
wait actually is that still a thing
if you're under the age of 30 drop me a
comment and let me know yeah either way
though we can create a massive
visualization tool out of a living human
being with a set of poi get geometrical
with your spinning take those shapes and
use them to demonstrate how they can
bring out different elements of the
music and make them even cooler how does
the music feel with triangles how does
it feel with curves how about with the
tension inherent in caps the sky's the
limit here
[Music]
so we have covered a huge amount of
ground here but the reality is we've
barely scratched the surface this isn't
intended to be a comprehensive guide to
absolutely every way that you can add
musicality to your POI dance it's meant
to be a primer to get you inspired and
give you ideas as you explore the world
of poi dance yourself you're going to
find lots of things that you think bring
out specific elements of music or add to
them I can't wait to see what those turn
out to be so I can get inspired by you
too
foreign
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
and I really hope you did because it
took months to research and write please
consider leaving me a like comment
sharing and subscribing to help keep the
conversation going to help make sure
this video will reach people who can
benefit from it and to help my channel
grow also real talk for a moment here I
can pretty much guarantee this video is
going to get demonetized I had to come
up with specific examples of the aspects
of music that I wanted to Showcase here
and that means that all the ad revenue
from this video will go to the people
who wrote the music that I featured and
you know what that's okay I don't mind
supporting musicians who have inspired
me but at the same time if you dug this
video and would like to see more like it
I I really appreciate it if you could
support it and my future work by signing
up over on my patreon just like all
these nice folks did my patreon
supporters very literally make videos
like this one possible by giving me
Financial backing to invest enormous
amounts of time into videos I'll
otherwise never see a dime from if you'd
like to sign up you can do that over at
patreon.com
drexfactor POI there you can get access
to a whole host of rewards including
extra footage that didn't make it into
this and other videos and even better
you'll be making it possible for me to
make more videos like this one give it a
look please and thank you has all this
inspired you to learn more about POI
dance excellent this is part of a series
I'm doing trying to distill down
everything I know about POI dance into
instructional video form you can see the
other videos in this series by checking
out the playlist that I'll link to down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video too so
give that a look as well thank you so
much for watching get out and flow today
and I'll see you with a new video on
Monday
peace